look at that face
cardi b and offset finally debut a first
look at their baby boy
more than half a year after welcoming
their bundle of joy and the couple
finally revealed his name
wave set cephas i don't know i just get
too emotional when it comes to my kids
the i like it rapper shared two photos
of the seven month old looking fresh as
he rocks a baby blue puffer jacket a
matching beanie and white kicks
also take a look at that ice on his neck
the baby boy is rocking a diamond chain
with a pendant that appears to be a
smiling blue shark riding a
diamond-encrusted wave on twitter
cardigan fans a closer look at the chain
and captioned it quote when seth
suggested wave i was sold that had to be
his name
you know what i'm saying offset gave an
even closer look at their baby boy with
this shot of the cutie shirtless shining
with diamond chains around his neck and
a diamond earring
the rapper captioned the photo of his
son quote wave set cephus in the
comments people couldn't help but gush
over how much wave looks like his big
sister three-year-old culture and they
are right take a look at the side by
side photo they're practically twins i
got two brothers three different dads i
never heard of like you know i'm saying
like a half brother like a that's my
brother so the first look photos of the
baby come as cardi offset and their
children pose for the cover of essence
in a video for essence uncovered offset
opened up about cardi treating his three
kids from previous relationships as if
they are her own it's a blessing to be
able to have them all together and have
a wife that's open and treat them as if
they have her kids like you know in this
day
you might not find that like it's not
that's not that's not something that's
always around you know what i'm saying a
love for motherhood is something cardi b
has opened up to e.t about here's what
she had to say back in 2019 shortly
after the birth of her daughter culture
what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile right it's automatic
worries
sad you know what i'm saying like i said
you know my baby had a cold
and i never felt like like so sad and i
wanted to cry and
so worried like i just
oh god it's crazy so it's everything
everything yeah she means everything to
you yes and i think i mean i mean
everything to her like i said when i she
sees me she kicks her feet so fast it's
like she loves me
[Music]
you